bien mes chers amis nous allons si vous
l'oubliez bien commencé avec le quart
d'heure habituel de retard c'est une
nouvelle journée de travail qui s'ouvre
pour nous une demi journée
on va aborder le sujet de la dépense
publique le sujet de la fiscalité
on va essayer de dire comment changer
d'une certaine façon l'économie la
macroéconomie celle qui dirige beaucoup
de la croissance française
cette journée de travail elle fait suite
à de nombreuses journées précédemment
dans tout cela une logique on a regardé
le régalien à la sécurité l'immigration
on aura actualisé puisque c'était déjà
au mois d'octobre
bien évidemment nous avons regardé le
marché du travail élément indispensable
de la reconquête française nous avons
également regarder chapitre très
important quelle ne fut notre secteur
public
notre fonction publique l'organisation
notre fonction publique ça a un poids
considérable en france mais nous devions
vraiment éclairé les choses avec un
éclairage nouveau c'est ce que nous
avons fait il ya quelques quelques
semaines mais aujourd'hui nous allons
parler d'un sujet ô combien sur lequel
nous sommes attendus au combien attendu
c'est évidemment le niveau de la dépense
publique
le niveau de la fiscalité les finances
publiques alors la france elle est sûre
fiscalisés la france elle est sûre
administrés la france elle est sûre
normalisée et donc la france elle est
sous compétitive et c'est vrai
véritablement là le sujet 6 millions de
chômeurs
une sorte de décrochage permanent de
notre pays c'est pas un tableau comme ça
pour donner le sentiment d'être
pessimiste de bon matin mais c'est la
réalité de la de la france des marges de
manoeuvre extrêmement faible on voit que
dans d'autres pays ils augmentent leur
salaire minimum on aurait bien du mal à
les augmenter toutes les marges sont
évidemment utiliser nous allons parler
de ce sujet parce que c'est la mère de
toutes les batailles
c'est la mère de la bataille de l'emploi
c'est la mère de la bataille du pouvoir
d'achat sur la mer de la bataille du
financement des services publics auquel
les français sont terriblement attaché
comme je le disais c'est évidemment la
merde
la bataille du redressement économique
durable de la france
alors c'est pas une affaire comptable
pour beaucoup de gens ou dans des débats
télé souvent on nous dit une vision
comptable cd vous donner un chiffre
une vision comptable comme si la
comptabilité serait un art mineur sa
enregistre un certain nombre de choses
et une vision comptable en général ça
veut dire dépenser tout ce que vous
voulez puis on verra bien c'est une
vision laxiste la vision non comptables
la vérité c'est que si nous voulons des
marges de manoeuvre nous devons juste
pouvoir espérer que notre souveraineté
soit pas uniquement une souveraineté
militaire
ô combien importante une sur une
souveraineté sur notre sécurité publique
mais aussi une souveraineté financière
nous devons juste est à la hauteur des
attentes de nos générations et nos
générations doivent pas laisser aux
générations qui viennent un endettement
excessif des charges qu'ils ne
pourraient pas payer ce sera évidemment
d'une brutalité absolument inouïe c'est
donc pas une affaire comptable c'est une
affaire de souveraineté mais nous allons
aborder ces sujets sans tabou avec en
parlant de principe
quels sont les principes qui doivent
gouverner les dépenses publiques elles
sont les principes qui doivent gouverner
la fiscalité
et puis évidemment pas uniquement en
rester là on doit parler de mesures
précises et vous savez ce que nous avons
dit à propos de l'élection
présidentielle et nous sommes en train
de construire un projet d républicain
pour l'élection présidentielle
vous savez ce qu'on a dit c'est qu'on
doit mettre un peu tout sur la table
pour que les électeurs puissent
évidemment choisir en bonne connaissance
et que les français après acceptent les
réformes qui seront nécessaires au
redressement du pays et donc il faut des
mesures précises suffit pas à dire il
faut moins d'impôts il faut dire quels
impôts dans quelles conditions
pourquoi et c'est ce que nous allons
faire alors on va commencer
d'abord avec une table ronde qui sera
animée par christian saint-etienne qui
est le délégué général à l'économie des
des républicains qui avec moi à
participer va participer à organiser
l'ensemble de cette demi journée
je voudrais aussi remercier toutes
celles et tous ceux qui dans les groupes
de travail
on travaille extrêmement activement à un
seul homme nous allons d'abord parler de
la dépense publique
c'est pas un hasard on parle d'abord de
la dépense publique parce qu'évidemment
il est impossible de baisser la
fiscalité
parce qu'il faut baisser la fiscalité
c'est pas un scoop faut baisser la
fiscalité
on va d'abord parce qu'on parlait de la
dépense publique parce que si on baisse
pas la dépense publique
on peut pas baisser la fiscalité donc il
faut d'abord évidemment parler la
dépense publique
on nous on va débattre du niveau de
baisse de cette dépense publique on voit
qu'on tourne toujours aux alentours d'à
peu près 50% de notre richesse nationale
en dépenses publiques alors là aussi ce
sont des chiffres qui ont déjà été
données qui ont déjà été évoqués lors
des différents débats mais c'est un
chiffre simplement qui est pas un
chiffre de mai mythique c'est un chiffre
qui se fonde sur à peu près la moyenne
de ce qui se passe dans les pays de la
zone euro convient je consacre au fond
de la richesse nationale à la dépense
publique ça veut dire aussi combien je
ne consacre pas à la dépense privée et à
l'investissement ou bien raisonner comme
ça et très sincèrement c'est plutôt
l'investissement dans les entreprises
qui provoque l'emploi plutôt que
l'investissement dans les
administrations publiques
donc tout le monde sera d'accord avec ça
je l'espère j'aurais pas le prix nobel
d'économie en vous disant ça enfin je
vous le dis quand même il faut aussi
dans le domaine de la dépense publique
une fois qu'on a dit de combien on
voulait réduire cette dépense publique
il faut dire où on va la réduire
comment où c'est des questions plus
compliqué en général tout le monde est
d'accord pour baisser les dépenses
unique personne n'est jamais d'accord
sur l'endroit où il faut la bc on est
assez habitué aux débats ce débat nous
l'avons très souvent entre
parlementaires entre élus nous l'avons
un peu partout nous l'avons dans les
entreprises
aussi lorsqu'on en parle on voit bien
que la meilleure des dépenses publiques
ces dépenses publiques dont on profite
de cela il faut pas la laisser les
autres il faut pouvoir les baisser on
voit bien que la technique du rabot ça
marche pas rabotée de manière uniforme
la dépense a ne fonctionne pas parce que
vous ne pouvez pas continuer à avoir les
mêmes politiques pour toujours moins
cher et un moment donné faut transformer
ces politiques et on est maintenant à ce
stade nous devons transformer nos
politiques publiques et on fera bien sûr
un certain nombre de propositions et
nous chiffreront il est à peu près 100
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
en moins que nous proposons nous
éclairons nous documenteront comme on
dit nous expliquerons là où nous pouvons
baisser la dépense publique c'est
d'ailleurs dans les documents qui vous
sont distribués et puis on va parler de
fiscalité alors on va pas uniquement
dire il faut réduire la fiscalité on va
dire aussi il faut réformer la fiscalité
ce que nous proposons c'est aussi une
réforme du système fiscal lui même quels
sont les meilleurs impôts faut financer
mais quels sont les meilleurs impôts
comment le faire au mieux pour
l'économie
quels sont les impôts qui sont nuisibles
d'une certaine façon à l'économie qui
tirent l'économie vers le bas
l'attractivité et la compétitivité et
quels sont les époques au contraire
doivent être privilégiés donc où doit-on
baisser les impôts et en contre choc ou
ne doit-on pas les baisser
et ça c'est très important et on dira de
combien nous pensons baisser les impôts
et nous dirons de quels impôts il s'agit
nous dirons aussi au fond quel est le
niveau de réduction optimale que la
france peut se permettre
et lorsqu'on parlera d'impôt parlera
aussi de charges sociales si les
prélèvements obligatoires que nous
visons les charges notamment les charges
qui pèsent sur les entreprises qui pèse
très cruellement sur les entreprises qui
tirent beaucoup les entreprises vers le
bas et donc la france vers le bas qui
empêche les entreprises de lutter à
armes égales avec d'autres pays
et puis nous verrons sur les impôts les
impôts que nous privilégions dans leur
réduction
tout ceci montre d'une certaine façon
qu'on a envie de mettre en avant
l'entreprise si nous n'arrivons pas à
créer une sorte de deux visions amicale
de l'entreprise dans la société
française eh bien on peut dire adieu à
tous nos espoirs sur le fait de
retrouver une société du plein emploi en
france
donc comment au travers d'une baisse de
la dépense publique d'une réduction de
la fiscalité privilégiée le
développement de l'entreprise
et d'ailleurs nous prolongerons cette
journée de travail par une autre
journée on verra quelle forme ça prendra
le sera peut être un peu différente où
nous parlerons l'entreprise elle-même
comment elle se finance comment on peut
réformer son financement
qu'est ce qu'on peut apporter comme idée
nouvelle on verra comment mieux associer
les salariés au développement de
l'entreprise on verra tout ce qui
concerne la formation professionnelle
les l'apprentissage comment essayer de
mettre nos salariés en tout cas ceux qui
travaillent sont pas toujours salarié au
fond est de moins en moins salariés
peut-être comment faire en sorte que les
français soient de plus en plus adaptés
au monde qui vient c'est à dire un monde
qui se transforme de plus en en plus
vite et ce sera un complément un
éclairage très complémentaire de ce que
nous dirons aujourd'hui
et puis on terminera après avoir vu la
fiscalité
on terminera par également une troisième
table ronde où on évoquera d'autres
réformes fiscales pourquoi parce qu'on
pense que il faut de temps dans la
réforme fiscale et dans la réduction de
la fiscalité
il faut un premier temps qui s'exerce
dès le mois de janvier 2017 agir vite
agir fort tout de suite
donc nous faisons cela en tête et on
vous dira comment agir vite et fort en
deux temps le deuxième temps et tente de
le situer quelques jeux ses parents
2019-2020 2018 on verra à un moment
donné où la france ce sera clairement
redressé comment faire en sorte d'avoir
deux temps un premier temps essentielles
nécessaires au fond on envoie
immédiatement beaucoup de beaucoup de
mesures qui ont un impact fort
et puis en même temps après on
accompagne cela on accompagne le
développement par la poursuite de la
réforme de notre fiscalité
évidemment chaque temps enfin les deux
temps sont votées en même temps tout ça
sera devant les français comment faire
un plan de réduction de la dépense
publique il est voté par les français
dès le mois de juillet et puis les deux
temps de réforme de la fiscalité même
chose votée par les français avec 2
quels impôts il s'agit avec des taux
avec une vision donner de la visibilité
aux acteurs économiques donner la
visibilité aux français nous allons nous
terminerons évidemment par l'idée de
maîtriser les déficits faut évidemment
tout ça ne nous entraînent pas vert
une replongée dans des déficits tout à
fait excessive que connaît notre notre
pays et vous verrez que ce que nous
proposons permet de stabiliser puis
après de réduire les déficits avec des
conditions de pression je dirais bercy
avec des conditions de pression qui sont
plutôt prudente quand on prend les
hypothèses que nous avons prises mais
nous verrons tout cela au cours du débat
alors trois tables rondes je vais
immédiatement leur céder la parole la
première table ronde
si je la trouve je vais y arriver elle
est animée par christian saint-etienne
vous allez parler de la dépense publique
est là christian présentera nos
interlocuteurs et nos amis qui sont ici
puis nous parlerons de la fiscalité vers
10 heures avec marie christine dalloz
qui animera les choses puis je
reprendrai un peu la main pour organiser
la troisième table ronde sur ce deuxième
temps fiscale comment poursuivre le
contrechoc que nous annonçons pour
juillet 2010 est par une autre choc
fiscal a en tout cas une autre réforme
une poursuite de la réforme profonde de
notre système de fiscalité de la
réduction de notre fiscalité puis bien
évidemment nicolas sarkozy viendra
conclure cette demi journée sur un sujet
aussi important que celui que je viens
d'évoquer
voilà je vais céder la parole donc
immédiatement à christian saint-etienne
pour introduire et pour organiser cette
première table ronde bonne demi journée
de travail